how do you do 9s can anyone give me a
suggestion because not everyone said
they had trouble with it who got it and
how did you approach it your talk us
briefly through it okay actually in
between yeah
yep they give us two fractions I think
these the ones with 9a and they say give
me one that will be right in between
them yes five cents now how did you know
where the 5/7 was right or not genius I
don't know it's a serious question I
think how did you know cuz this is
important for all of us
how can we judge whether that's right
yeah it just it just sort of it my
spider-sense tinker with when I wrote it
down okay yeah okay with that yeah
three quarters and fish yep and then I
just tried to okay till I've got one
left in between this okay all right
right good
now a couple of different perches here
first was guess and check okay second
was this circle method right which I'm
biased toward because that's the way
that I showed you with the pies before
like okay here's my question to you
right have a look at this exercise have
a look at the whole all the different
questions right what's being asked of
you right what are they what skill are
they trying to get you to develop and
the answer is it's this kind of skill
this comparison right by getting a
common denominator right now can you see
how that would be relevant to this what
would be if we could have to choose one
what would be the common denominator
between three quarters and four bits
yeah sure it'll be xx again one of the
same kind of in fact it's you know
that's we've got the same numbers here
right he loves common ones words 20 so
now if I rewrite these as equivalent
fractions right over 20
what would 3/4 be it'll be 15 on 20 well
done because for to get that denominator
20 your multiplied by 5 so do the same
thing to the time okay
now what about this one you've got to
multiply top and bottom by 4 so that
gives you 16 over 20 okay now stop look
haha yes yes yes now these are right
next to each other on this number line
right where would they be sorry
15 and 16
but remember what I did over here I drew
a number line and then I zoomed in by
changing the denominators right you can
do the same thing over here by changing
these into a cooler factions one more
time here's I'm doing if I make the
denominator bigger so now I've got
smaller little slices but more of them
okay I multiply by 2 and over to here
and one thing this by 2 over 2 as well
you see how they're all equivalent you
see it can you see it
ah now you can see a fraction between
them 31 over 40 will do it and by the
way when you're ready we don't really
well so far let's try to finish it off
when you do 31 over 40 right that looks
like it's kind of the perfect answer
because it's like right in the middle
between them but there's actually
infinite number of fractions in between
these two just for the sake of
illustration what I did from here to
here right which is multiply by 2 over 2
I can just do it again
can i what would it become 360 on 80 and
this would be 64 okay oh look now you
can see there's some more fractions in
there 61 62 and 63 on a and I can keep
on going forever okay yeah I know I'm
just illustrating the fact that you dope
there's not that's why they say find a
fraction not find the fraction because
it's not just one